ces mères ont entre leurs mains toutes
les doléances des habitants de leur
commune dans ses cahiers se trouve la
parole des français et leurs
revendications abandon de la vitesse à
80 km la sto ration hull dans nos
campagnes référendum initiative
citoyenne
monsieur madame ont passé une journée
dans une école de quartier ou dans une
ferme au lieu de rester enfermé dans
votre bureau
prenez le rer au lieu de votre voyage
lire dans ce monde devenu fou chez
l'exploitation des personnes qui
travaillent la voiture ou pour gagner
obligé de la prendre
trop peu de transports en commun pas
assez de commerce de proximité retrait
de la csg sur les retraites coup de
pouce aux petits de l'argent pour tout
ça nous avons j'en suis sûr de
nombreuses idées tva 33 % sur les
produits de luxe plus établi qu'il y ait
une liste sans fin de doléances qui
serait très vite indigeste
je préfère vous emmener une journée dans
la vie d'un de ces ruraux avec ou sans
gilet jaune et ruraux que vous méprisez
souverainement et que vous prenez deux
au lit avec alien doléances des choses
écrites et puis elle ce qu'on entend ce
qu'on nous dit parce qu'un grand nombre
de gens non mais je vous le dis vous
aurez calme transcrire ou transmettre
donc à l'écrit et l'oral des doléances
remise aujourd'hui à emmanuel macron par
l'association des maires ruraux de
france
au total plusieurs milliers de mairie
ont participé pour alimenter le grand
débat national